The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DUANE BONING: So
what I'm going to do
is pick up a little bit where
we left off from last time.
Last time we were
talking, primarily,
about full factorial models.
And then we dealt with a few
important additional issues
in experimental design.
So we were talking
about issues of blocking
against nuisance factors,
kind of a practical issue,
but that also got us into
a generic issue that's
actually much more fundamental
and important of confounding.
And I want to pick up on this
issue of confounding today
because very often you will
want to do fewer experiments
than a full factorial.
That 2 to the k
grows very fast--
grows exponentially fast with a
number of factors, for example.
And so very often you
might ask the question,
can I reduce the
number of experiments
and still get the key
information that I want to?
And so that's where
we'll really pick up
with fractional factorial
designs today and understanding
confounding and
aliasing patterns
that come with different subsets
of a full factorial design.
Then we'll touch on
some implications
for model construction that fall
out pretty naturally from that.
And then start talking
a little bit, hopefully
if we have time, on process
optimization using some
of these kinds of
design of experiments
techniques and the models
that we're building.
So as I was saying,
very often we
want to run fewer than that
exponentially growing number
of experiments, even if
it's just to level, building
simple linear models.
Again, we've got a 2 to
the k exponential growth.
And, as an example,
imagine we said
we wanted to run less
than the full 2 to the k,
say, for three inputs--
so for three inputs, if we
run the full 2 to the k.
And we wanted to form a
full linear regression
model with interactions--
so it's still on quadratic,
but it does have all
the interactions.
This is what the
model looks like.
And it's got, if
you count them up--
it's got eight coefficients.
So if we were to do less
than the full 2 to 3
or 8 experiments, we
obviously would not
have enough data points to
uniquely fit every coefficient.
So that's already giving
us the biggest clue.
Is if you do less than
a full factorial model,
then even for
linear experiments,
you won't be able to fit
all of the coefficients.
So what you end up having to do
is make a decision, a priori,
that some of these factor
effects are going to be small.
That is to say, we're going
to treat the coefficient
as essentially zero.
But then what's
happening with the data?
What impact does that have
on other coefficients?
So we can explore that slightly.
Here's an example.
We'll call this a 2 to
the 3 minus 1 experiment.
And I'll talk about these half
fractions a little bit more.
But instead of the full 2
to the 3 or 8 experiments,
we'll do a half fraction here.
We'll just do 4 experiments
instead of the 8.
And so if I were to pick my
factor levels on x1 and x2
and then think about what the--
so I'm just doing--
in my mind, I might think if
I were just doing 2 factors,
I would have a full
factorial on to 2 factors.
And I also could calculate what
an interaction term would be.
That's fine, that works well.
I've got 4 coefficients
and a 2 factor experiment.
And that I could uniquely fit
all of those coefficients.
However, what if I were
to simply relabel that.
And instead of thinking
of that as an interaction,
what if instead I labeled
that an x3 column?
Then I could fit the linear
term for an x3 model.
So imagine I was
doing a 3 factor,
but only worried
about main effects.
I wasn't looking
for interaction.
I didn't care about
the x1, x2 interaction.
If I did that, and just defined
x3 as if it were that column,
then I've got a 3
factor experiment,
but I can only see main effects.
But you see what's
going on here,
I still have that
interaction term.
I still have an
x1 x2 interaction.
So the key idea of confounding,
that we saw before,
is lurking in here.
If I were to do
truly a third factor
and set on my control knobs
for that experiment, my x3
according to these
high-low settings,
those would also give
me the same information,
if you will, the same
combination settings for x1
and x2, that I would
have used to help
me detect an the interaction
between x1 and x2.
That is to say, the
x1, x2 interaction is
confounded with a third
factor, if I were to do it.
Just expanding on that a
little bit, if I were--
this should be a hat.
There's another little
weird font thing going on.
If I were doing a 3 factor
experiment, truly a 3 factor,
I could build up to a
linear model OK with those 4
experimental parameters,
but I could not
fit any interaction terms.
So I have a choice
in my model building.
Do I take my three factors and
look for just main effects?
Or do I stick with
my two factors
and look for an interaction
effect and not model at all--
pretend the third
factor doesn't matter
or try to keep that constant
and not let that enter into it?
Question--
AUDIENCE: If you
computed this [INAUDIBLE]
you still can't say
for sure that it
was x3 or [? x on ?] x2.
So you describe it
[INAUDIBLE] you really
have no way of knowing, right?
DUANE BONING: So if--
so the question-- by the way,
could we put the back screen
also to the slides?
Great, thanks.
So the question is, we
can still distinguish
x1, x2, and x3 or not?
AUDIENCE: No-- x3--
the effect that
we ascribe to x3--
x1, x2.
So we cannot differentiate
between the two.
Or [INAUDIBLE] might tell
us we have a huge effect
because of x3--
a significant effect.
So we're not really
sure if it's x3
that's having an effect or
an interaction of x1, x2.
DUANE BONING: Yeah, you guys
may not have heard that,
but basically, just
had the restatement
of exactly the issue.
That it's confounding
between is it an x3 factor
or is it a beta 1,
2, x1, x2 factor.
You cannot distinguish
between the two.
AUDIENCE: So should
we do something
different to find that out?
DUANE BONING: Yeah,
so the question
is what would you do then?
There's a priori knowledge
that may guide you to a belief
that there is no
interaction effect.
That there's no
possible physical way
there could be an interaction
effect, in which you'd
should be safe.
Or you might be
trying to say, I'm
not even sure either of
these effects exists.
And so I'm quite happy to
do just four experiments.
Do an ANOVA that tells me
is either of those, just one
or two, significant.
In which case, now
I worry-- maybe
then I add experimental
points to differentiate.
So we've talked a little
bit more about that.
But that's, in a nutshell,
the confounding and aliasing
thought process.
And we'll look at
some rules of thumb
that would lead one to believe,
for example, that I may have,
in many cases, more of an
a priori belief that maybe
the main effect will be
stronger and more important.
And I doubt that the interaction
effect will be there.
But those are kind of rule
of thumb and assumptions
that if you can do the
experiments, you can check.
So the point out of
this was simply--
again, these should be models--
y hat models.
For exactly the same
table of settings,
if I looked at it one way,
I could build a model where
I've got some interaction term.
Or I can look at
the main effect.
Or I can give up--
so this could have been
the x3 main effect.
Or similarly, I could
say, get confused
between some other main effect
and an interaction effect.
In other words, I've got four
coefficients, four experiments.
I've got some
confounding going on,
but it's not clear actually.
I've given you the
example for one of them
in the previous two slides.
But the same thing
holds true for any
of the other interactions
with one of the main effects.
So if I really
have three factors,
I might really
have eight kinds--
in a linear model--
I might actually
have eight terms.
And what I've done is
folded four of them onto
or confounded them with four
of the other coefficients.
And so then the question becomes
what's confounded with what?
How do I structure and
how do I pick which
subset of experiments to run?
So this is, essentially,
just saying the same thing.
The point is we can
carefully pick which subset,
in many cases--
this kind of a very small
experimental design.
But in many cases,
we can pick which
subset of the rows
we want to take,
which have a fraction
we want to do,
based on our belief
in which interactions
are going to be least
likely or least important.
So what we want to do is get a
little bit of a feel for that.
So here's a little
bit larger picture,
as well as now extending
some of our shortcut
techniques, our terminology,
our little factor algebra
that we've got for defining rows
and columns in our experiments.
So if I were doing
a three factor
experiment, a full 2 to the 3
array, this is our x matrix.
The identity column--
the C column--
you can sort of see I've--
all low, all high.
And then within that, I've got
the B columns, low and high,
low and high, low and high.
And then within each of those,
low-high, low-high, low-high,
low-high.
So that's, again, all
16 of the possible--
excuse me, all eight of
the possible combinations.
And then we can construct
our interaction terms.
These are two
factor interactions.
And then we've got a three
factor interaction as well.
So that would be all eight
of our model coefficients.
The column would tell me
how to form the contrasts
for detecting or estimating
each of those interaction
terms in the model.
So that's just our baseline.
And now let's consider
what happens--
let's think for this full
2 to the 3 experiment.
If I were to only do
half of the experiments--
let's say I did the upper half--
the top four, the shaded four
experiments only, what happens
in terms of what coefficients
can we estimate?
What ones can we not?
Please come on in.
So which coefficients can I
estimate and which ones can
I not?
And what's confounded with what?
We just got some
visitors filing in.
I think there is, perhaps,
some bench space over there,
as well, if you need some.
So everyone in Singapore wave.
Wave to our guests.
Great.
So if we do just this
upper half fraction here,
let's look at a couple of things
that are immediately obvious.
One that's really obvious here--
look at the C column.
If we do those set
of four experiments,
can you estimate what the
C effect is going to be?
No, we haven't excited
that variable at all.
It's all four experiments, we're
at the low setting of that.
So it's clear, if I
picked those four,
I'm basically making an upfront
decision that the C effect--
I'm not going to
be able to model.
be able to fit it.
I'm not going to know
if it's significant.
I'm not exercising
that variable in a way
with the right
combination of experiments
to unambiguously say,
yes, there was a C effect.
So one way that we can describe
that in our funky DOE algebra
is to say that the C column
is equal to minus the identity
column.
It's just minus 1 times
the identity column.
And we can also look at
some of the other columns.
And here's a neat one.
Let's say-- let's look at this.
The AC column, right
here, and the A column.
And again, in our
funky algebra, you
can see already this
AC equals minus A.
But if you look in one
to one correspondence,
the AC column is exactly the
same, just with a minus sign.
The same combinations
of levels as the--
both the A and the AC have
the same combinations.
So that's confounding
or aliasing
between those two columns.
So even if I run
this experiment,
there's no way for
me to differentiate
whether it was a main effect, an
A effect, or an AC interaction.
Now the other point here is
with just this selection, again,
of the top four
columns, the same thing
happens to other columns.
What's the B column
confounded with?
No, we've got some--
somebody leaning against the
wall trying to stay awake,
I think.
The disembodied
voice in the machine
said to tell you that
that's happened before.
So the B column is
also confounded with--
let's see, what?
Minus 1-- this one.
And then finally, the
last one is the AB column
is confounded with--
let's see, that's just minus
1 of the ABC, it looks like.
Do I have that right?
Yeah.
So that was our point here.
If I had all eight
experiments, I
could have fit eight
coefficients in the model.
But four experiments-- I can
only fit four coefficients.
And it's more important than
just fitting four coefficients.
It's really that I folded
together the effects of two
of those columns
into one coefficient
that I have to
assign either to--
sort of nebulously--
either to one
or the other of the main effect,
or the interaction effect,
or to some superposition
of the two.
So this is just, basically,
saying the same thing.
I'm just pointing out--
looking at the columns,
you can see that.
And if you were to actually
follow through and use
our contrast map for picking
out and detecting what
the contrast for effect A or
the contrast for effect AC
would be, they're essentially
the same contrast.
The same sum of the output rows
for that particular effect.
Now, we have a shorthand
way of describing
what this confounding pattern
is in our funky algebra.
Which is to say, we equate
what columns are equal to what
columns.
And then do a little bit of our
algebra of multiplying a column
factor or level
setting by each other
until we get down to
the identity column
on one side or the other.
And then that becomes
a shorthand way
of describing what the whole
confounding pattern is.
So for example, I can
pick, actually, almost any
of these confounding patterns.
Looking at the AC in
the A column, where I
detect that the AC and the A--
this was the A column is equal
to minus of the AC column.
Now if I multiply both
sides by the A column--
A times minus AC--
then on a element
by element basis,
if I take the A column there
and multiply it by itself,
every minus 1
multiplies by minus 1.
And I get the identity.
Over here I've got
A times a minus A.
And that also
becomes the identity.
And I end up with just the
I equals minus C. Which
I could have also looked
right directly at the column
and said, OK, what is
aliased with the identity?
But also so you get a little
familiar with that funky column
math.
So that, basically,
is a shorthand way
of either describing the
interaction effect or more
usefully, if I
knew up front what
interactions I was willing to
confound with what effect--
If at the start I said, I really
believe that the BC interaction
is going to be minor compared
to some other effect,
then I could use that to
actually help guide which
half of the experiment to pick.
So for example, I could
have picked this half
or I could have
picked this half.
And each one of those would have
been consistent half fractions.
And the choice of what
to pick depends on--
for example, do I think
AC is an alias with A,
maybe, because AC
really shouldn't
be interacting with each other?
I'm happy to do that.
But the AB interaction,
I might actually
be wanting to detect that I'm
willing for that to confound
with the B factor
because I think that that
may be less important.
AUDIENCE: Just
seems to be asking
that A is a processes pressure
and that C is the temperature--
for sure temperature.
So in that case, the
interaction between pressure
and temperature, AC,
if temperature is high
and pressure is
low with the same,
the interaction would
be the same as A?
Because that A is equal to AC.
DUANE BONING: Yes.
AUDIENCE: It will just change
one parameter, just temperature
[INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: But
what it's saying
is that your model, then,
for what the A affect was,
wasn't purely an A affect.
It had a little bit of the
interaction lurking in it.
So when you actually
run that experiment,
if there is an
interaction, you can't
tell whether it was due to
the main effect of pressure
or also because of some
interaction with temperature.
So it's not that you get both or
you only get one or the other,
it's that they're
mixed together.
They're confounded together.
So I alluded to some of the
ideas of how you choose which
design, based on what
confounding you're
willing to live with.
But there's also a few
additional guidelines
that are at work.
One is, there's this idea of
balance and orthogonality--
that I'll talk about
in just a minute--
that tells us you can't just
willy nilly pick random rows
out of your matrix and be able
to use our design experiments
and that analytic techniques.
Things like the estimation
of the effects and so on only
apply if I've got balanced
and orthogonal experiments.
And that leads, also,
a bit, to this idea
or very closely
related to the idea
of getting enough
excitation of the inputs.
So going back to our 2 to
the 3 full table here--
this idea of balance,
first off, says
that in whatever subset
of the design that you've
got for the factors that
you're interested in,
you want all of the columns to
have an equal number of plus
and minus signs.
Now, we saw if I did the
upper fraction for C,
if I was trying to
deal with C, that's
not balanced because I've got
four low settings and zero
high settings.
I have not at all
excited that input.
But if you think back
to all of our algebra
for dealing with
contrasts and being
able to take the average of
this, and the average of that,
and subtract the two
with the contrast,
that's basically
the reason that we
need this idea of
balance between the high
and the low settings for
that particular factor.
So to use our
shorthand approaches,
you need an equal number
of the plus and minus signs
in each of the
columns that you are
trying to use in your model.
Turns out you can relax
that a little bit if you
do some regression approaches.
There's some other
risky, nasty things
that happen like
you may not have
the same amount of
variance or residual error
at different points
in your experiment.
But especially for the
shorthand approaches,
you have to have this
notion of balance.
The second idea
is orthogonality,
which is basically
saying that what I need
is for the sum of the product,
element wise product of two
columns, to sum up to 0.
So for example, here,
the column A and B--
this is a product of one--
product minus 1, product
minus 1, product of 1.
Those sum up together to be 0.
The A and B columns
are orthogonal.
Which is another way of saying
those two columns are not
confounded with each other.
So think in a linear
algebraic sense.
If the two vectors
are orthogonal,
they are not mixing
together effects in any way.
So if I have two
columns that I want
to be able to model
separately and not
have the coefficient
trying to mix in randomly
some amount of one or
the other, but, in fact,
to be identified with
that particular effect,
those two columns
have to be orthogonal.
So for example,
what that's telling
me is if I were to pick
this upper half fraction,
the A and the B
columns are orthogonal.
They are not confounded
with each other.
They are two main effects
that, at least with respect
to each other, are separable.
You could ask that same question
now to our other confounding
patterns.
What did we say?
A is confounded with BC--
was it?
So A and BC--
are those two orthogonal?
Certainly, we know
by confounding,
they're not supposed to be.
And if you do that product
of sums, each one of those,
I believe--
AC, sorry.
Good-- I was about
to say, that's weird.
They look orthogonal.
There we go.
Each one-- the product
is minus 1 every time
they all sum up to minus 4.
They're not orthogonal.
They are mixing in together.
So those are a
couple of these ideas
of balance and
orthogonality that
are in some sense the same--
just another terminology for
talking about the same thing
that we've already built
up some intuition about.
So I think we've already
just went through that.
So if I were, in
this experiment,
doing a half fraction and
picking the upper column,
you can see things like A
and B are balanced, C is not.
So I can't try to put
that into my model.
A, B, and C are orthogonal.
Let's see, is that right?
Yes-- so if I were--
except I'm already knowing
I better not try model
C because I don't have
sufficient excitation in there.
But I could also then
ask, OK, what else
is confounded with each other?
And if there are places where
I don't have orthogonality,
I might then be led to is
there a different half fraction
that I might want to pick.
One might be this lower one.
I've already looked
at the upper half.
But couldn't there be other
meaningful combinations?
And the answer is yes.
So for example,
here's a better subset
if I were looking for a
particular property that was
annoying with the previous one.
In particular, this fact
that I can't even model.
I'm not even exciting
a main effect.
That feels weird.
So a better half
fraction, then, at least
lets me look at main effects.
Might be this shaded
blue half fraction.
Now look what's going on.
All three columns A,
B, and C are balanced--
just the shaded blue parts.
So I've got equal
numbers of high and low,
each of A, B, and C are
mutually orthogonal.
I still have
confounding going on.
I'm not sure quite
exactly what this means.
I guess A-- let's see.
I still have confounding
because, for example--
So A is not orthogonal
with what column here?
BC in this one.
Because 1, 1 minus--
so these are the same.
So these two columns are
confounded with each other.
So those are not
mutually orthogonal.
And I could ask, OK,
what is a shorthand
way of describing this?
I could pick a couple
of these columns
and say A equals BC and do,
again, my funky algebra.
Multiply both sides by
A and get I equals ABC.
And there's my
defining relationship
for what's confounded with what.
Could also look up here,
again, and ABC is exactly--
for the blue-- for that subset--
for the blue element
is confounded
with the orthogonality matrix.
What might be better about
this design or this subset
than the previous one?
Depending on what you're
looking for in the--
what's better about this?
Here we have, I guess,
shorthand for us--
what the other aliases are.
Again, we expect to have
four aliases because I'm only
doing four experiments.
What do you see
about these aliases?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
high and low values
for all the main effects
and one only third order,
like ABC, is the one that
you have not excited at all,
it's the one that [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Good--
so that's at least two
of the three properties that I
really like about this design.
If everybody didn't hear
it, he said, at least
you're exciting A, B, and
C. Second, the only column
that you're not exciting
at all is a third order
interaction, which is fine.
How likely is a third
order interaction?
We'll chat about that
a little bit more.
There's another
additional effect.
There's another additional
really nice characteristic
about looking at these
aliasing patterns here.
AUDIENCE: Like, A
is [INAUDIBLE] BC
so they're not measuring
exactly the same amount.
DUANE BONING:
Right, they don't--
I don't know quite what--
don't overlap is a nice
way of describing it.
I've got a main effect
that is confounded
with an interaction of somebody
else's second order term.
So it kind of gets around
that discomfort with A
being compounded with AC
that you were describing.
Now, I still have to worry about
it because if any second order
effects are out there, if
AC is still active, now
I'm not confusing it
with A main effect.
I am confusing though
with the B main effect.
But the nice thing is now I
can- you'll see it a little bit
later--
I can also appeal to
some physical causality
to also talk about the
likelihood of it being
a main effect or an interaction
effect, when I finally
analyze my overall experiment.
What am I saying?
Here's the peek forward at that.
If I were to find that this--
either the B main effect or
the AC interaction is at work,
but I also did an ANOVA
and I found out already
that this was not
significant, in other words,
they're not an A main
effect, it's highly unlikely
that there's an
interaction with A.
If it doesn't have
an overall effect,
why would it have a
subtle interaction.
It's kind of unlikely.
So by ordering
this, you actually
can start to decode what's
going on in the process
with a little bit
better visibility.
So what we're actually
talking about here
there is some
additional terminology
for which is design resolution.
It's basically a characteristic
of the aliasing patterns
and how decoupled you are able
to get between main effects
and interaction effects or
second order interactions
with other
interactions, and so on.
And you will hear, sometimes,
description of particular half
fraction or other
experimental designs, DOEs,
as being resolution three, or
resolution four, resolution
five.
And a resolution three
is a weaker ability
to discern than a higher
resolution in your experiment.
But a resolution three is
nice in that no main effect--
an A factor is alias
with another main effect.
So A is not alias with B.
But you will have main factor
and other interaction aliases.
Let's say you didn't want that.
You might need to
build a more powerful--
do more experimental
combinations.
And you could go to a resolution
four, which is essentially
designed as an experiment
where no main effect is
an alias with
another main effect.
And I'm not even
aliasing any main effect
with its second
order interaction.
I might be so worried that there
are second order interactions
that I have to
make sure that I do
enough experimental points to be
able to detect them separately.
Do an ANOVA on significance
of each of them separately.
The example that we did just
a second ago, what resolution
do you think that is?
It's only resolution three.
We were clearly
seeing interaction
with the second order effect.
If I wanted to get to resolution
four, what would I need to do?
It's the full
factorial, in this case.
I'd have to go to
the full 2 to the 3.
I couldn't pick a half fraction.
So if there were
four factors, it
turns out you get 16 columns.
And now I can pick 16 rows.
I can pick up 16
columns and rows.
But I can pick, now, some
subset if I did a half fraction
and still achieve a resolution
four if I wanted to.
So this is just looking
back, again, at the column.
Again, the main effects are
aliased with interactions only
in this defined experiment.
And that, you will sometimes
see referred to as a 2
to the 3 minus 1 sub resolution
three experimental design.
So now, if you see the
shorthand notation there,
you look and go, oh, that's a
half fraction because it's a 2
to the 3 minus 1.
And it's resolution
three, telling you
something about the aliasing.
AUDIENCE: In the
previous chapter,
is the difference
between resolution 4
and 5 both have no [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: So there
was a subtle point
in here, which is no main effect
interacts with a second order
interaction.
But I might have a
second order interaction
aliased with another
second order interaction.
The resolution five says,
no second order interactions
are aliased with any other
second order interactions.
So here we've been talking
about half fractions--
2 to the 3 minus 1, especially
as the number of factors
gets large.
Let's say I have a design--
I'm designing a process and
it's got eight different control
knobs.
That's a 2 to the
8th experiment.
That's an awful lot of
different combinations.
I might not want to just go
down a 2 to the 8 minus 1.
I might want to do even
lower half fractions.
For example, if
I cut it in half,
and then cut it in half again,
that's a quarter fraction.
I'm only picking a quarter
of the full factorial.
And again, there
would be a resolution
associated with that.
You could look and see what is
the aliasing pattern with that.
And as you get to the
higher order models,
you will often see
increased half fractions
in early parts of
experimental design
where you're just trying to see
are the main factors important.
And might there be some
second order effects,
some second order interactions,
at least detecting
whether they exist.
And then if they
do, you'll often
then go back in and start
filling in the other parts
of the experiment.
Here's another half fraction.
Trying to think-- this
is, again, for our 2
to the 3 minus 1.
This is a different set of four.
It's just got a different
defining relationship.
And you could, again, ask, in
this case, is that-- number
one, is that a
legitimate half fraction?
Could I legitimately pull
these four columns out--
four rows out?
What kind of balance do I have?
What kind of orthogonality?
Or what's aliased with what?
And you can either
do it by looking at--
you can detect or
decide what are
the aliases by
looking at the columns
or simply doing your
little math down here
from the defining relationship.
So if I start with I
equals AC and say, OK,
what's aliased with C?
So I do C times I equals CA C
equals A because the C times
C is the identity, and so on.
And similarly, I
could say, OK, if I
start with I equals
AC multiplied by B,
I get B equals ABC.
There's that.
So there's a main effect
aliased with the third order.
That's not too bad.
I don't really like that
A aliasing with C. That's
not even a resolution
three experimental pattern.
So I'd be very
careful in using this
unless I really
believed, strangely,
that C was not going
to have a main effect
but I might be worried
about it or interested in it
for the purposes of
looking for interactions.
There is one other subtle place
where you might actually--
nope, never mind.
I've already alluded to a
couple of ways of deciding what
aliasing pattern to choose.
The most important one is your
knowledge of the process--
your experience
with the process.
What factors are
likely to actually,
based on physical
causality, interact.
But there are a few very
important rules of thumb
that are worth mentioning here.
They are this idea of sparsity
effects, hierarchy of effects,
and inheritance.
And we've already talked
qualitatively about them.
But just to nail them down--
if I have eight factors, the
experimenter, you, likely
has a certain amount
of a priori knowledge
that there's an ordering and
likelihood of those effects.
But it's also the case, I
have different eight factors
on my experiment,
it's highly likely
that they don't all equally
influence the process.
Most processes have
a top few factors
that have most of the influence
or most of the effective.
It's like a Pareto
type of a rule.
So early on in
screening, in fact,
you might be very happy doing
one of these half fraction,
quarter fraction, and so on.
The purpose of
which is really just
to narrow down a really large
number of candidate effects
down to a smaller
number that you're then
going to model more accurately
and look for interactions
among those large effects.
So this sparsity
of effects is one
of the things that's at work
in early screening experiments
and is a good rule
of thumb a rule
or a generic effect to be
able to take advantage of.
The second one is this notion of
hierarchy, which is basically--
again, these main
effects are usually
more dominant than
second order effects,
which are more dominant than
third order interactions.
Furthermore, usually
you have to--
not have to-- but
usually, you will
see that the main effect or
the lower order interaction
has to be at work before you
have substantial interactions
with some other factor.
So it's going to be rare
for you to have a big AB
effect and no main effect with
A and no main effect with B.
So that's another rule
that you can often use.
And the likelihood of
having these very high order
interactions--
the idea that you will have an
extra delta in an eight factor
experiment attributable to
exactly the combination of all
of those settings
being important
or large enough to be
important is pretty small.
And then, I guess, I've actually
mixed in the inheritance here
already.
This idea that I really
need both of these factors.
So the hierarchy
is really just more
saying the size of the
effect, schematically pictured
by the size of these boxes.
The main effect
tends to be larger.
And then the inheritance is I
kind of need the lower order
interactions be at work.
So here's just some
additional examples
in the context of
half fractions.
We've already almost
exhaustively explored the 2
to the 3 minus 1 resolution
three kind of picture.
Here's an example
defining relationship
for resolution four.
And here, you really have
to get up to four factors
before having
enough leeway to be
able to have that kind
of an interaction pattern
where I would only have--
so, for example, now
if I did the algebra,
A would be confounded with BCD.
Or if I multiplied AB on
one side, AB is equal to CD.
So that was the
earlier question.
There you can see, a two-factor
effect or two way interaction
is confounded with another
two way interaction.
But all main effects
are only compounded
with three way interactions
and none with each other.
And here would be an
example you can play with
to see what the aliasing pattern
would be with a resolution five
kind of experiment.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the 4 minus 2 design--
is that-- would that
have-- what's the identity?
DUANE BONING: I think that--
the identity-- I don't
remember offhand.
I think we've got, actually,
an example right here that
shows what the aliasing
pattern would be.
You asked exactly the question.
And so we can work it out.
So here's an example.
First off, we already
know it's probably not
going to be a defining
relationship like this one
because I've only got 2 to the
4 minus 2, which is 2 square.
I've only got four experiments
out of the 16 that I'm picking.
So I've got an awful lot
of confounding going on.
And the question would
be, I can actually
build it and look and see what
the confounding pattern would
be.
And in particular, I might
want to pick it such a way
that I want to at least be able
to detect the four main effects
and lots of other things
could be aliased in with that.
So I could build it a
priori and say, OK, I'm
willing for A to be aliased
with that and with that.
So in this case, when you've
got a double half fraction
I'm going to have aliasing be
between more than two columns.
Now I actually have multi-way
aliasing between three columns.
So in essence, what I've got
is something like A equals BC,
D equals ABC.
And then you can work that
out as I is equal to ABCD.
In this case, is equal to BC.
So it still has this
defining relationship,
but I'm now only picking
four of the rows.
So I don't know if
you guys can see that.
It's kind of tiny.
But this is all 16
of these columns.
And, again, this is
the same combination
that I just went through before.
If you look, the A column here--
these four-- minus
1, minus 1, 1,
1 is now aliased
with both the BCD--
where'd that go-- the BCD minus
1, minus 1, 1, 1, and the ABC
column, minus 1, minus 1, 1, 1.
So if I do that, I have folded
two other columns onto it
in order to get down to
the full half fraction.
And you can also explode
out in the other direction
and see what are all of the
interactions and aliases that
go on, again, either
looking at the columns--
and here, I've
shaded the columns
that are alias with each other.
So in each case,
we've got all four.
Or you can do the column math.
And this has another
nasty effect,
which is those four columns
are not even resolution three.
So going back to your
earlier question,
I don't know what the defining
relationship is for a 2
to the 4 minus 2
resolution three.
I'm not sure what the
defining relationship is.
Sounds like a good
problem set problem.
Remember that one.
So I think we've
explored aliasing.
Do you understand aliasing?
Any questions on the aliasing?
Confounding?
There is one more
aspect to it that I
want to explore a
little bit, which
is, what are the implications
for model construction?
We've already alluded to this.
So let's just sort
of work through it.
But also, folding in and
remembering interaction terms,
but also, potential
higher order terms
and some implications that
arise if-- some of my factors,
I think, might have
quadratic elements to it.
You get, actually, then
complicated aliasing patterns
in those cases.
So a simple case, when I just
got one input and I've got one
output, but I think there
might be a quadratic effect,
what we're seeing here is that I
cannot do just a two level full
factorial to exercise that.
As we talked about
last time, I have
to add some kind of a
center point or some other--
I really need all three
data points in order
to be able to fit
a quadratic term.
And we talked last
time about being
able to do ANOVA
residual analysis
to differentiate whether
that deviation compared
to spread within a replication
error is significant.
So I could decide whether that
coefficient is significant
or not.
If I were generalizing this
now, to more than one factor--
last time we talked about
a two factor example.
And we had up to
second order terms.
But if we expand this
out to a full quadratic
with all of the
interactions, what you see
is a very rapid explosion in
the number of coefficients.
Because I've got
my main effects--
so this is still
just two factors,
but now tree level-- a full
factorial in three levels.
I've got my average.
I've got my main effect.
I've got my interaction
between x1 and x2.
But then I've got, also, x1
squared and my x2 squared.
And then I've got the
interaction between x1 squared
and x2, x1 and x2 squared.
And if both of the
terms were squared,
the question is, do I have--
this is what the full
quadratic model with all
of the interactions would be.
Do I have enough data to
be able to fit this if I
did a three squared problem?
Why not?
How many coefficients
do we have?
AUDIENCE: You have one extra.
DUANE BONING: Do
I have one extra?
One, two, three--
I have nine coefficients.
How many experiments
is three squared?
Nine experiments--
so it's exactly
like what we saw with
the two experiments.
I have exactly, just barely,
the number to perfectly fit.
So actually, if I do the
regression formulation,
which I think is coming--
ew, nasty-- think
these are supposed
to be vertical dot, dot, dots.
And these are supposed to be
horizontal dot, dot, dots.
Weird font problem here.
If I were to actually formulate
this for the three factor,
I would have exactly the
same matrix relationship.
And I have exactly the same
number of rows and columns.
And I would be
able to fit that--
I guess that doesn't
come till later.
I could solve that
directly and get
beta is equal to x minus 1--
my output.
But I don't have
any replicate data.
If I had replicate
data, then I would also
need to do the pseudo
inverse exactly as before.
So the point the
point here is if you
want to build every possible
model in the full quadratic,
I have to have a full factorial
in three levels, as well.
So we can meaningfully talk--
although you don't
see it that much
in the literature and
we'll see why in a moment,
you can talk about full
factorial more than two levels.
I'm talking about
full factorial 3
to the k, where you've
got three levels per test.
But what you will see and I
want to touch on a little bit,
are slightly
different designs that
have a couple of
additional properties
that might be a better
way to go than starting
a priori with the full
tree level factorial,
doing every possible
combination of all three levels.
But rather, start with
the two level experiment.
And then if you start to see
some important interactions
or some indication
that additional effects
are needed, adding experimental
design points incrementally
when it's easy to do that.
It's not always easy to do that
in your experimental setting.
AUDIENCE: How would
you detect that?
Would you say other--
observe other effects?
DUANE BONING: Yes, so if I
do purely the corner model,
is it possible for me to detect
if there might be curvature?
No.
So the first thing I would
do, if I wanted to detect,
is at least add
some center points.
And certainly, for
continuous parameters
we talked about last
time, that makes sense.
It doesn't make sense
for discrete parameters.
Really, curvature is only
a term that makes sense
with a continuous parameters.
So that's kind of the
domain I'm talking in here.
So in fact, my rule
of thumb is I always
have at least the center
points in my original design.
I never do just a pure
two level factorial.
I always add at least the center
points because they tell me--
and I try to replicate at
least the center points
so I can distinguish between
curvature and I can also, then,
not fit exactly perfectly
every interaction,
but I can also start
to ask questions
about the significance
of these effects.
Then I've got some indication
that there might be curvature.
Now I might go in and start
to say, OK, there's curvature
but I don't really
know the nature of it.
Now I want to add these three
level points on more than one
of the experimental factors.
That's where I might then add
even more experimental points.
But I'm always shocked
because a few of the books--
you read Montgomery,
[INAUDIBLE],,
you read most of the
experimental design books.
They rarely talk and emphasize
the value of the center point.
It's just absolutely
crucial in my mind.
I always want to add at
least that off corner--
one off corner point.
And preferably some
replicates of that
because it gives you
so much more power.
And think about it.
If I'm doing four
factors, I'm only
adding one more
experimental combination.
I'm not exploding
out the whole design.
It's a very cheap way
to learn an awful lot
more about your experiment.
So this is simply
making the point.
We just looked at
the 3 to the 2 case--
how many coefficients there
are in the full model.
In particular, if we do the
full model quadratic 3 to the 2,
we already got
nine coefficients.
But if I add just
one more factor
and I'm still worried
about the full model
with all of the
interactions, the number
of experiments that I need
to do explodes rapidly.
Up here with only five
factors, I got 243 model terms.
Do you really think each of
those model terms is going
to be nonzero significant?
Probably not-- so this is
also a wonderful opportunity
for saying, sparsity of effects,
hierarchy, all of those--
I'm going to alias some
of those in and discount
certain interactions.
And in fact, if I just do main
effects and the third order
term, but only on
the single effect.
So an x1 squared--
second order term, quadratic
model, x1 squared, and x2
squared, and so on--
then it only grows linearly
with the number of factors.
If I know a priori, I can
neglect those higher order
interactions.
So this is just working
out and giving an example,
now using some of our
earlier terminology.
Again, here I can refer to
the different combinations.
Again, I have my A and B. And
I can label the AB interaction.
That's that AB interaction
or the AB effect
goes with the Beta 1, 2.
This A2 is just an a squared, B
squared, A squared B, B squared
A, A square B squared.
And you can, again, see,
now, the factor levels where
I've added 0 to indicate
the center level setting
for each of those.
But we can also
borrow, and import,
and use all of the same
aliasing terminology
that we had earlier.
So for example, if I only did--
I don't know a--
well, if I did a 3
to the 2 minus 1,
I guess that's a half fraction,
but kind of an odd one
because that means I
get to pick three rows.
I could pick-- is that right?
I think that is.
You'd have a lot of
aliasing going on.
So actually, it's not as easy
to talk about a half fraction.
And in fact, we'll see--
I can do these aliasing,
but I want to leap ahead.
Here we go.
A good way to try to
visualize these, which
works for lower
number of factors
because it's not too
high dimensional a space,
is actually plot out in your
x1 versus x2 experimental space
what design points you're
actually exercising
with some half fraction.
So for example, in this case,
I'm just doing say, these 2/3
and leaving off this
1/3 of the experiment.
In which case, what
I'm essentially doing
is giving up and saying, I'm
not going to do the high level
setting on my x2 factor.
And now you can start
to get a good feel,
nice intuitive feel
that goes together
with the mathematics,
of what you're
giving up when you do that.
If I were not doing
those experiments,
I just picked this subset,
what model coefficients am
I detecting or am I
going to be able to fit,
and what am I not
in that experiment?
Should be pretty intuitive.
What model coefficient
would I not be able to fit?
Next to what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING:
Yeah, for this one.
No worries-- I said, we are
going to pick these six points.
These are the six columns
going with these rows.
But I'm not doing
those three experiments
in my x1 and x2
factor [INAUDIBLE]..
Can I do a quadratic
model in x1?
Sure, I got three data points
projected along in that.
Can I do a quadratic
model in x2?
No, I'm only exercising
two different levels.
So I can only go up to
linear in that term.
And that's what I
mean by intuitive.
I think you can start to see
what, at least main order
effects as well as second
order terms, are at work.
It's a little more
subtle to see,
can I do an x1 and x2 or
an x1 squared and an x2?
I think you can see,
I've got combinations
to be able to do some
of those, but there may
be some confounding going on.
And then you can look
back at the columns
to see what kind of
confounding may be occurring.
So I haven't actually
done that on this
to figure out which is
confounded with what.
But let's see-- anybody--
it's probably so tiny
you don't have a hope
in the world of seeing it.
There is one.
B is equal to minus B
squared, in this case,
where B was my x2.
So this is basically
confounding and saying--
I was telling you,
I could not fit
the B squared-- the
quadratic term in x2.
If there actually is
curvature, where did it go?
It's hidden inside of
the B2 linear term.
It's confounded with
the B linear term.
So it's the same
kind of terminology.
Here's a different pattern
that looks almost the same
as the other one.
I can still fit quadratic
in x1, linear in x2--
in fact, it's not
even clear to me
right up front what I can't
fit with one or the other.
I kind of like having the center
point in the other design.
But now, what's the
difference between these two?
Actually, I think a lot of the
aliasing is relatively similar.
I can think of one reason
why I might pick the lower
design over the upper design.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't it make
the effect more pronounced?
DUANE BONING: Yeah, I
think that in combination
with what I was thinking,
but I think you're right.
The statement was,
this would make
the effective more pronounced.
I'm also thinking it explores
a larger space of x2.
This one is just zeroing
in or zooming in on the 0
to low setting.
The other one goes all
the way and spans the low
to the high setting.
So I'm exploring or fitting
around the larger portion
of the space.
So I might prefer, for
that reason, the lower one.
It doesn't have a
pure center point,
but it's not clear that
the other one does either.
AUDIENCE: Is there [INAUDIBLE]
DUANE BONING: Yeah, so
the same idea is a balance
and orthogonality are at work.
But again, it's mostly
with respect to--
it's more subtle
now because it's
with respect to
either the linear term
or the quadratic term.
So these are both balanced
and orthogonal with respect
to things like the
main order effects.
But not orthogonal B to B
squared in these two cases.
So you can use the
same reasoning.
But you've got
three levels, you've
got to expand it out
and think it's not just
the whole variable
or the interaction.
It's also the second
order term, possibly,
being nonorthogonal
with a lower order term.
Here's another one.
What do you think about that one
compared to the previous two?
This one looks
interesting to me.
AUDIENCE: It's
going to be bigger
because we can do
quadratic [INAUDIBLE]
and since the combinations
are less-- they
have less effect [INAUDIBLE].
DUANE BONING: Yep--
I'm not sure
everybody heard that.
But at least here, we're
exercising all three levels
of x1, all three levels of x2.
So we can fit quadratic
terms in each of the cases.
Where we might need
to be a little careful
is we're actually making
an interesting trade
off here-- going back,
also, to your earlier point.
We're giving up a little bit
of balance in this design.
In that for the
low setting of x1,
I've actually got more data
than for the high setting of x1.
And so if there's
noise effects, I'm
actually fitting, in effect--
if you do the regression, you'll
have a narrower confidence
interval over here
at the low setting
than you would at
the high setting.
So you actually have
to be a little careful.
You can do the regression math.
You have to be careful
in forming your contrast.
Normally, you get to
these high r models,
you're probably throwing it
into a regression anyway.
But you also then have to be
careful in the interpolation
and use of the model in
different parts of the space
because its accuracy
is a little bit
different in different
parts of this space.
But I like this--
I kind of like this one is as
well, even with those caveats.
But you can still use this and
the same aliasing terminology
to figure out which
coefficients I'm giving up.
What's aliasing with what.
And I'm not going to go through
that, but you can do that.
AUDIENCE: Would you get
a higher [INAUDIBLE]??
DUANE BONING: Well,
it's not clear you
would get an overall
higher or lower r squared.
You almost always-- and we'll
do a little bit more regression
later.
But you almost always,
if you add more terms,
you get a better r squared.
But then the question
is, is it a fair model?
So we can also talk
about an adjusted r
squared where you penalize
for the additional model--
the additional model in terms.
And then this is
just pointing out
that you can still use
the linear algebraic--
either direct solution or quasi
inverse solution if you've got
replicates to be able
to fit the model.
So these are the sorts
of things that come out.
This is for an x1, x2.
I don't know which is which--
x1, x2.
If, in fact, there are
true quadratic terms,
these are a little
different kinds
of surfaces than the
ruled surface, which
looked like it had kind of a
funky kind of curvature because
of an x1, x2 interaction.
But if I projected down
on any one variable,
it's always linear.
Here, if I were to do a
slice holding x1 constant,
I do, in fact, get
a true quadratic.
Now, the nice thing
about quadratic surfaces
is you can start to think about
an optimal point much more
easily within these.
Certainly, if the
space is large enough
to cover a minimum or a maximum,
there's a natural motion
if you're trying to minimize
or maximize your output
y of finding the optimum space.
Now, it's also possible
that if I had a smaller
space in the true
minimum or maximum
of the full equation where
outside, then I might have--
so for example, let's say
my space was constrained
to only right here,
then I might run
into the minimum or the maximum
at one of my boundaries.
But now we've got
this extra notion
that my min or maximum
might occur somewhere
in the interior of the space.
As opposed to with
linear models,
it's always at one or the
other of the boundaries.
So this starts to
get to the desire
for using this
kind of a model now
to find the optimum point, which
is one of the main reasons we
do experimental designs.
Not just to find out
which factors matter,
but build the model, and
then use it either in,
maybe, feedback control or
more often, just to set--
find the process settings or
find the design optimal point
in order to achieve
some criteria.
Now, I alluded already to
adding additional points.
If we did a full
factorial three level--
that's all nine
combinations of high-low.
And in the x1, x2 space,
that's all nine points.
There is an alternative
approach and probably one
of the most important
experimental designs
after two level full factorial.
It's referred to as a
central composite design.
And you often will design
up front to do this,
but also very often
it will be what
you extend a full factorial
corner point design with.
If I did my first
experiment with 2
to the 2, just pure full
factorial two levels,
and I got four tests, first
off, this is probably wrong.
The model is shown
to have a poor fit.
If I actually did this for all
four points in the interaction,
I don't have enough
to detect that.
So somewhere in here
would be ad center points.
The power of the center point.
If you remember nothing
else from today,
the power of the center point.
The power of the center point.
Then I can start to
detect whether it actually
has a lack of fit
in a formal sense.
And let's say then I decide
I want to go quadratic,
but I'm not quite sure
of the shape where
my min or maximum might be.
What we often do is add
our additional points.
So there was our original
four corner points.
Certainly, we wanted to
add the one at the center.
Should have done that already.
But now I can also decide
where to add my interaction
points different-- so
let's say I added this.
The full typical 3 to
the 3 would say, OK,
you add them at exactly
these 3 by 3 grid array.
I would add them at the center
points of each of these.
We can do something else
that's a little bit clever.
Which is instead, add
these interaction points
off the grid, but at the
location of an outer circle
equidistant or circumscribed
around the original points
of my cube-- my hypercube.
See I think-- there we go.
So what we would do
in that case here,
is these would be my
first four points.
I'd add my center point.
And now I add these
points off axis.
There's something really clever,
really valuable in doing this--
some things that are subtle, and
kind of mathematical, and not
all that important, but
some other parts that
are really nice and intuitive.
I'll give you the subtle
mathematical part.
This actually maintains
a little bit of fitting--
if you go and you
do the regression,
the fact that all of
your off center points
are now equidistant
from the center point
means that your model variance,
no matter which direction you
go, is the same.
In other words, there's
a confidence interval
on your coefficients and an
interpolation or extrapolation
error that grows
as you go further
from the center of your design.
And by doing this, that
maintains asymmetry.
It doesn't matter which
direction you look.
You've got the
same model accuracy
purely as a function of
distance from the center.
So that's a nice
mathematical property.
But there's another
more intuitive value
picking these corner points.
And the way I think
of it is if I just
picked those 3 by 3
on a regular grid,
I could then project
down to x1 or x2.
And then in terms of
exercising the x1 variable,
I've only got three levels.
Here, if I were to
project down my points--
so let me get rid of some
of this scribble here.
If I were to project down
onto just my x1 axis--
let's say I did the
experiment and I
found that x2 actually
was not that important
and I project down
all of these points.
That means for my
x1, I've actually
exercised at five
different levels of x1.
I've got more than just--
I've got extra
redundancy built in.
If I'm fitting just
a quadratic model,
I've got ways to actually check
whether the quadratic model is
sufficient.
I can do a lack of fit test
on even the quadratic model.
Whereas if I only had
exactly three samples of x1
and I add the
quadratic in, there's
no way for me to
ask the question,
might there be an
even higher order,
a logarithmic dependence,
or something else
that's subtle that's going on.
Because I fit exactly all
of the data that I have.
So the central composite
design, I think,
has this nice
intuitive feel of I'm
actually kind of exercising my
space a little more thoroughly
to be able to build a model
that can apply a little bit more
broadly.
Everybody see that?
So here's what the central
composite would look like.
What you end up with is the
original coroner points.
You add the center point.
And now you can see, if you
were to do the geometry,
the distance there
is square root of 2.
So I'm going a full one
on both the x1 and the x2.
And you can extrapolate that
to a third order hypercube.
I think it ends
up being, instead
of square root of 2, that
distance is a square root of 3
and so on.
So you can find
what the distance is
and pick those
different corner points.
So what we'll do next time
is build on a little bit
this idea of using the model.
We built it.
We can assess it.
We can pick our points to build
different orders of model.
What we'd like to do is talk
a little bit about picking
one of these surfaces
and how I actually--
a couple of related,
but slightly different
ways of looking at optimizing
to find an optimum point either
after you've built
the whole model or--
the clever thing here when
you're on a process line--
doing it interactively
or incrementally.
Actually, picking your
design points almost one
at a time based on your current
view of the model driving
towards the optimum.
So instead of doing all
your experiments up front,
you might actually want to do
them in an evolutionary way
to try to find the optimum.
So we'll talk about both of
those approaches next time.
So again, the problem
set is due tomorrow.
I think we'll hold off and we'll
give ourselves, Hayden and me,
an extension on
issuing the new problem
set so you're not doubled
up, and we can think about it
a little bit more as well.
And issue that
tomorrow, as well.
We'll see you then on Tuesday.